a conference center converted to an
enormous makeshift Hospital part of
wuhan's response to the flood of new
infections
Chinese State television broadcast
footage of recently completed hospitals
with multitudes of doctors taking care
of few patients
but secretly recorded videos from
hospitals paint a very different picture
body bags containing the dead lying
close to patients even in Waiting areas
this citizen journalist visited four
hospitals in Wuhan
people are not being informed about the
real situation
State TV doesn't go where it hurts but I
think this needs to be seen
the journalist found more body bags
outside One hospital
inside he saw dying patients together in
one room
he posted his videos online
officials had him arrested then released
him after a public outcry but in China
his online videos have been deleted
now a cruise ship carrying people who
may be infected by the deadly
coronavirus has returned to Hong Kong
after being denied entry to Taiwan
Health officials say that 30 members of
the crew are showing symptoms
the world dream has returned to Hong
Kong though it remains unclear whether
passengers will be allowed to disembark
coronavirus symptoms can take two weeks
to surface meaning suspected carriers
must remain in quarantine for at least
that long to prevent further
transmission
Health officials have begun testing the
passengers and crew on board with
confirmed cases already being sent to
hospitals
the ship's arrival came as Hong Kong
health workers began a third day of
strikes in the city they want a meeting
with Hong Kong chief executive Carrie
Lam to discuss officially closing the
border with mainland China a move they
believe would halt the spread of the
coronavirus that has infiltrated Hong
Kong and already killed one man
um we urge her to solve this situation
by coming out to reach us and talk to us
the World Health Organization has
declared the virus a global emergency
but not a pandemic in other words it
might be spreading but don't panic
currently
we are not in a pandemic
we are at the phase where it's an
epidemic with a multiple Foci and we
will try to extinguish the transmission
in each of these foci
China was praised this week by The Who
for its reaction to the outbreak with
the virus relatively well contained
until now
its arrival in Hong Kong represents a
new challenge this government must now
also prove it is equal to the task of
dealing with it
and for more we go to Charlotte Chelsea
pill our correspondent in Hong Kong who
is at the harbor there and Charlotte
we'd like to ask you what is happening
with the passengers on board that
quarantined cruise ship because we heard
that there was a man taken from the Hong
Kong Cruise liner into the ambulance
after a coronavirus check
well this is clearly going to be a very
anxious wait for the passengers on board
this Cruise liner as they're facing an
additional extra night now quarantined
here in this cruise ship now what they
don't know at this stage is exactly how
long they will be there authorities uh
have not said how many more nights they
could be facing here uh quarantined on
this ship what we do know is that
several of the crew members were
displaying symptoms they've now been
taken off the ship and are being tested
for that new coronavirus we also know
that on board this ship on a previous
trip there were three people from
mainland China who were then diagnosed
with the new coronavirus and it is that
which is causing so much for concern for
people on board this ship every now and
then we hear announcements as telling
people to thanking people for their
patience saying it's not clear when
they'll be allowed to disembark that
testing is being carried out every now
and then people coming onto the
balconies just behind me just to have a
look around just see what's going on
looking at the Press pack below
reporting as this situation unfolds so
what is the mood there given all of that
Charlotte and and how much of a risk is
Hong Kong really facing from the
Coronavirus
well everybody here has very painful
memories of the SARS virus back in 2003
which almost 300 people lost their lives
in a in a densely populated city like
Hong Kong with such close ties to
Mainland China this is an area where
this virus could spread very quickly and
of course everybody knows that it could
take up to two weeks before people
display symptoms that is causing a great
deal of worry here that is exactly why
Carrie Lam encouraged people today to
stay at home to not go out unless
necessary to wear face masks as well
people that we've spoken to say though
that they ideally want all of the
borders with mainland China now to be
closed it's for that reason that medical
staff are on strike at the moment
demanding just that saying Hong Kong
needs to take as many preventative
measures as possible to stop the spread
of this virus Carrie Lam announcing
today further measures she said anybody
traveling from mainland China will now
be quarantined for 14 days as of
February 8th in an attempt to try and
stop the spread of this virus Charlotte
Chelsea pill in Hong Kong thank you
Charlotte